شرعت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
التحقيق بشان تسريب وثائق فائقه السريه
تتعلق بالنزاع في اوكرانيا كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
حيثيات تسريب وثائق فائقه السريه من
البنتاجون تماثل شكل الاحاطات المقدمه
لكبار القاده ومن المستفيد من كل ذلك ما
حجم تاثير هذه التسريبات على استراتيجيه
الغرب في دعم اوكرانيا ومسار المعارك مع
روسيا وعلى علاقات الولايات المتحده
بحلفائها وكيف ينظر حلفاء واشنطن الى مدى
خطورتها وانعكاساتها عليهم وما هي
تقديراتهم لحجم الضرر والتداعيات
يعطينا فكره عما تفعله وتفكر به الولايات
المتحده حول الحرب في اوكرانيا وما يفعله
الاخرون لمساعده في معرفه ماده الضرر
الاصابه روسيا واصابه اوكرانيا في هذه
الحرب وكذلك تتناول موضوع كوريا الجنوبيه
واسرائيل ومصر نعم الى حد بعيد نحن واحده
من اخطر عمليات الاختراق او التجسس او كشف
المعلومات السريه التي تحدث منذ على الاقل
عقد من الزمن نتكلم على ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه
الجزء المتعلق بحجم وكم هذه الوثائق حتى
هذه اللحظه تم الكشف عن على الاقل 100
وثيقه ما بين سريه وسريه للغايه وحدناك
حديث حول مئات الوثائق التي سوف يتم نشرها
خلال الفتره المقبله الامر الثاني متعلق
بالمضمونه المحتوى والنطاق وبما يعني ليس
فقط الامر متعلق بخ حرب الموجوده في
اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق باستعداد القوات
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه كما
يتعلق بالدعم الاوكراني وفيما يتعلق
بالحمد القادمه بعد شهر من الايام يطلق او
الحمله المضاده المضاد الاوكراني على
روسيا
امريكا اتكلم على حلفاء
وتقل امريكا اسرائيل كندا كوريا الجنوبيه
الامارات ومصر هؤلاء هناك تسريبات خاصه
اما تامر يحدث ضد امريكا وعلاقات على
المثال الامارات وبين روسيا تبادل
استخباراتي على مستوى عالي جدا هناك ايضا
حديث حول امكانيه قيام مصر
وامداد روسيا بما يقدر ب 40 الف قاذفه
صاروخ نتكلم ايضا على تسريب متعلق
بالتحريض المساعد الاسرائيلي للمواطنين
الاسرائيليين ولضباط المساعد بالتضاهر ضد
نتنياهو فيما يتعلق بما يعرف بالاصلاح
القضائي الامر الثالث متعلق بتدعيات ذلك
على مستقبل علاقات الامريكيه مع حلفاء مع
حلفاء حلفاء
ربما لعبت دورا في هذا الامر لانه عندما
ظهرت الوثائق هذه كان لديهم عدد اكبر من
الضحايا التي كانت
تكبتها روسيا ثم قلل الرقم الى الرقم غير
واقعي
[موسيقى]
هناك شعور متزايد بان هذه التسريبات تمثل
يعني خطوره عاليه ليس فقط لما تحتويه ايضا
التوقيت التوقيت مهم جدا من عده جوانب
بجانب الاول هناك استعدادات على قدم وساق
من خلال دعم امريكي ودعم غربي خاصه حلف
النيتو لاوكرانيا هناك خطط للقيام بعمليه
مضاده كان هدف منها محاوله استعاده اقليم
دومبا احتلاله قبل حوالي عام من الان
وبالتالي هناك عمليه كشف لسريه هذه
العمليات والامر الثاني متعلق بالصراع
الصين الامريكي قد يكون هناك تدخل صيني او
دور صيني في هذه المساله من مصلحه الصين
ان يكون هناك نمره التوتر ليس فقط فيما
يتعلق بحبل ايضا في التوتر بين امريكا
وحلفائها
[موسيقى]
المدى القصير قد يكون هناك نوع من التضرر
او نوع من المشاكل في العلاقات الامريكيه
مع حلفائها على مستوى المدى الطويل اعتقد
العلاقه الامريكيه مع هذه البلدان علاقه
استراتيجيه علاقه مهمه جدا علاقه حيويه
حتى وان بدا ان هناك حتى هذه اللحظه نوع
من الانزعاج من الانسحاب الى الامريكي
المنطقه العربيه حتى وان بدا هناك ظهور
بديل لقوى دوليه وهي الصين فيما يتعلق
بالعمق الاستراتيجي الدولي الى ان تظل
علاقات الامريكيه محالات مهمه واستراتيجيه
تعود لعقود الصعب تتاثر على مستوى الطويل